welcome to this video playing blitz game
against melo Milo from Greece what yes
so let's see you Queens gambit yeah I
Queens gambit I could play the reducing
without knowing too much about it let's
see what happens when I studied that
here's this years ago I intended to play
with h6e not the most aggressive way to
play but still found is solid ok so i
guess i'll take a place he 5 get them
the seaborne involved i have the two
bishops that's nice but other than that
it's it's a pretty equal position yeah
taking what the point is so probably
best maybe a rookie able to get on the
d4 pawn I think this is still a known
position if not it's very similar to a
known position interesting 96 should i
do that and probably answered on d5 I
can take c6 is you three sorry d5 take
c3d 5ed 95 is nothing nothing too
worried so on d5 i can i can take this
is good the question is what am I
playing if he goes rock do you want
which looks I like I just take you for
hmm maybe you want to do nighty for
maybe
and now the question is who where where
do you go now and to f4 possibly what do
you seven now let's go let's go to a
phone I can I can't drop back to c7 and
maybe the bishop all the way back to f8
if he attacks it hmm you had to know
probably this is about equal of this
position but it's not so easy to play
for both sides actually ok I'll drop
this Bishop back it just expose done
before and at the moment if he goes d 5
which is the move i always need to look
for or calculating i can i can take yeah
I interesting I could I could go to
g-form try to harass up a bit here not
sure see some looks very very normal ok
so why not I mean maybe King King g2
yeah he's just developing okay how to
how to continue I could play maybe night
b4 to d5 try to block or just Bishop d7
yeah Bishop d7 others st5 but I can take
em pleno create okay that's compared
yourself also I also try to not fall too
much behind on the clock Bishop d7
Bishop e8 young okay this is probably
okay there's no other way to develop the
bishop I think b6 was not on because his
success I was hearing so Bishop d7
probably the the way to complete
development yes but is really okay I
could I could take it yeah I could maybe
I need to
there's no tactics 94 this 54 okay take
it and we should be eight to use the
default yes but I thought this is
actually week pawn maybe I'm wrong as
possible always hard too hard to
evaluate preparing b5 at Queen B form
okay he's covering that what about I
have an interesting idea maybe it's
nonsense night b8 intending be sure to
c6 ok maybe at the moment if he if he
moves he cannot if he moves the night
I'll exchange and this is ok for me if
he ok I thought I'm ok am I not like f6
and I mean d6 it's it's a I can maybe
maybe I can just pick it up at some
point or this one is probably better
maybe I'm far too optimistic here and
I'm not saying I'm better but i think
this pawn is still something that i can
maybe win the king is near
and maybe you can take a play Bishop
Bishop c4 intending f5 King f7f 50 and
now I play that one and I think our
group t6 not maybe f5
okay so if i take it
hmm yeah that's not so easy rooks is
seven but i've got i can go here
intending rock d 7 yep this i have the
check coming check and maybe i should
have thought about this a bit longer
it's very hard to win check probably
Jack and win him
okay checked I'm warning check check
okay complicated my phone is quick
I'm upon down but it is hard once the
scan oops yeah I wasn't I wasn't
expecting Kings if I Jack asleep white
forfeits on time oh I didn't really pay
attention to the clock yeah no idea what
was going on at the end here I mean the
airport is dangerous prolly probably
this should still be okay for me yeah I
didn't expect that at all I mean I Roxy
one actually wins now introducing those
ideas yeah I lost a bit and ladders
control him but I probably need to do
something else in this position this is
quite quite annoying okay probably this
is bad i need i need to do something
else maybe something like this try to
and try to improve the King first and
then go for more what I did I really
didn't see is that in this position I
thought yeah this is the Chadron but I
thought that check maybe something like
this but I must be cautious there's also
f5 and this is a mating net along these
lines let's say random move check check
check check me and made so it's very
tricky yeah this is still ok you can
play a 52 maybe something like this it's
still okay for him this wasn't necessary
really f5 is not so good yeah this is
good f
it keeps control over the position yeah
complicated stuff thanks for watching